hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
what i have right here is the ipad air 4
from
apple we just got it on friday and we're
going to be comparing it to
samsung's galaxy tab s7
this guy right here is 600 for the ipad
air and 650 dollars
for the tab s7 right now so in this
video we're going to be comparing
everything between the design the
displays the display quality the
speakers
the cameras microphones everything you
can imagine so we can give you an
answer on which one you should be buying
in
2020. what i have right here are the
official
cases and the pencils for each of these
devices
they're actually swapped but i'm going
to be getting into these a little bit
later but first let's
start with the design by far the best
thing about the ipad air 4
is that it's taking on the design of the
ipad pro
or the 2018 ipad pro because we have
that single
camera lens right here we've got flat
sides all the way around
which is a really nice and modern design
that's
exactly how the iphone 12 series is and
honestly i really really love this
design and of course the tab s7
also got the design from the 2018 ipad
pro it kind of copied it
you've got the flat sides and i think it
actually has the film still on here so
i'm going to take that off
so now that we got the film off you can
see that we have like this brushed
finish on the sides of the samsung and
they do take in
fingerprints quite a bit more than the
ipad air because this is aluminum so
it's nice and matte
it's not very slick but yeah this is the
design from the 2018 ipad pro
the 2020 actually has a square camera
bump with the
ultra wide lens and the lidar scanner
which the air does not have
however the tab s7 as you guys can see
right here
it does get the ultra wide camera so
we're going to be testing that in just a
second
comparing the size you can definitely
tell that the ipad pro
is a little bit wider than the tab s7
but the tab is actually a little bit
taller so they have different
aspect ratios and in comparison with
thinness it looks very very similar
however if i'm looking
very closely i think the tab seven is a
little bit more
thick now getting into the other
physical differences we do have four
speaker grilles on both sides so on the
ipad air
we have two on the top tablet seven same
thing and on the bottom we have two
there as well however the ipad air only
has
dual speakers it doesn't have quad
speakers like the tab s7 has so we're
definitely gonna have to test that out
the ipad air has the pencil connector
right here on the side just like the
ipad pro does so let me grab that pencil
really quick
as you guys can see pencil right here
magnetically attaches
right on the side this is actually
pretty nice and it
automatically charges connects
everything like that
and with the tab seven simply just snaps
in right there on the back this little
plastic or glass piece i'm not sure but
very nice now we'll get into the
performance of these a little bit later
on the bottom we have usb type c on both
of these tablets which is the
best connector for a tablet for sure
now the final difference i want to get
into is touch id
or the fingerprint sensor now both of
these tablets have that that's really
unique about the ipad air 4.
it's basically the first ipad to have
touch id in
the power button right here and they
totally just redesigned this
they've never had a power button touch
id like this before of course they had
it on the home button
which was on the front and it looked
pretty bad of course
now we're saying that but yeah this has
it on the front
and the tab s7 has it right here on the
side
so let's test out which one works better
or faster
let's first start off with the ipad air
okay there you go just locked me in
automatically that's what's nice about
the
power button touch id is that you can
turn on the display
and unlock it at the same time now the
only downside i see about this
compared to the ipad pro which has face
id is
i'm used to tapping the display and
swiping up to unlock because face id
happens automatically this does not have
that
you have to use the touch id now let's
try out the
tab has it right here look at that
try it again all right i have to say the
tab is faster
i don't know if it's the animations but
it gets you in
almost instantly so i think the tab is
the winner for the
fingerprint scanner comparison now let's
go ahead and compare
the displays on both of these as you
guys can see we have
rounded corners which is really nice and
modern
but if you look at them more closely it
looks like the bezels
on the ipad air are quite a bit more
thick than the ones on the tab s7
so we did compare to the ipad pro and
you can easily
tell the difference there as well so the
tablet 7 has
i guess a better looking display with
thinner bezels
now one thing i did notice is that the
tabas 7's display
looks gray right now like i don't know
if it's the reflections
but the ipad air has a very deep black
display like everything looks very black
compared to this looks kind of gray so i
think
the coatings maybe are better on the
ipad air
now in terms of reflectivity oh yeah
the tab seven right now looks like a
mirror i can see our microphone right
above
very clearly compared to the ipad air
it's all kind of soft
it's not as reflective so there's
another point
for the ipad air and now let's compare
the maximum
brightness of both of these displays as
you can see i have it maxed out on the
air and the tab of seven true tone is
off
and it looks to me it looks to me like
the tava seven
is brighter honestly and if i lift it up
point it towards that camera you guys
let me know
which one is brighter but to me it
definitely looks like the tab is
brighter
and the ipad airs display looks very
cool
right now with true tone off so that's
very very interesting
now let's get into the display quality
and as you guys can see we have a
display p3 color gamut test
and you guys should be seeing the webkit
logo on the ipad air
but you don't see it on the tab s7 i
guess it can't do
p3 colors i've been testing it out and
nothing
nothing showing up now the reason for
that is because
the tab s7 at least the regular one no
longer gets an
amoled display only the s7 plus gets
that display
now the nice thing is that it does have
120 hertz
refresh rate and we're gonna get into
that in just a minute
all right guys now this is interesting i
turned on an 8k hdr
video and the tab s7 has controls for
hdr
but it can go up to 1440p the ipad air
on the other hand
does not get hdr but it gets 4k
resolution which is
very interesting that's awesome so let's
let these play and compare the quality
as you guys can see even though the tab
s7 gets
an hdr option the ipad air just looks so
much better
the colors pop more it actually looks
brighter
even though it doesn't have hdr and
because the display has better coatings
where it's deeper
you got deeper blacks everything
actually looks
better there's more contrast and the
image on the ipad air is just
killing the image on the tab s7 now
let's finally get
into the 60 hertz versus 120 hertz
display refresh rate comparison
obviously the ipad air gets 60 hertz
instead of the ipad pro's 120.
that's a big downside that it does not
get promotion
and that's a huge upside for the tab s7
as you guys can see right here on the
display
with adaptive you're getting up to 120
hertz refresh rate
so let's go ahead and compare it now you
guys are looking at
slow motion clips from the top camera
and as you guys can see swiping left and
right through the home screens
the tab seven is just so much more
smooth
and then also while going through a web
browser page
you can just see how much smoother the
tab seven is and this is actually going
to make it feel more snappy
it's going to make it feel like it has a
lot more performance
which we're actually going to be testing
a little bit later and of course the
display refresh rate also impacts the
performance of the pencils
so the s pen because of the 120 hertz it
gets a latency as low as 9 milliseconds
so what you guys are seeing right now is
a slow motion 120 fps
comparison so let me know down in the
comments below if you can notice a
difference in latency and if the s pen
looks
more smooth and now let's finally get
into the speaker comparison between
these two
quad speakers on the tablet 7 dual
speakers on
the ipad air now i do want to mention i
have dolby atmos
on on the tab of 7 so you guys always
ask about that
let's get right into it
[Music]
all right so you guys just heard that
let me know what you think down below
but to me
the tabas 7 is the clear winner it
killed it in everything volume
phase mids highs everything the quad
speakers
destroy the ipad air and i think samsung
has been killing it
in the speaker game for a couple of
years now now let's get into the camera
comparison
i'm going to be starting off with a
selfie now let me know which one of
these selfies
look better down in the comments section
below and in just a minute i'm going to
be doing a webcam and microphone test as
well
now on the back of course the tab s7 has
a leg up on the ipad air because the
ipad only has
one main wide shooter compared to the
tab which has
an extra ultra wide camera so i'm going
to show you guys some photos right here
let me know
which one you think is better which
quality looks better and of course
how that ultra wide lens looks let's now
get into performance with geekbench five
the ipad air has four gigs of ram
compared to six on the tab s7 so there's
a pretty big advantage there if you're
doing multitasking but right now let's
get into the cpu
benchmark all right we have our scores
and this is just
insane it's ridiculous both of these
tablets have i guess the best of the
best the latest processors
we have the a14 bionic on the ipad air
that also comes on the iphone 12 lineup
very very fast and we have the
snapdragon 865 plus
the best of the best for android and
looking at these scores
i mean the single core score on the ipad
air is the best score we have
ever seen on any device any computer
it's insane just about 1600 points
compared to 971 on the tab s7
and then in terms of multi-core
performance we're getting about 33
percent
more performance with the ipad air
compared to the tab seven that's that's
just insane
all right now because geekbench isn't
that good for comparing the graphics
performance
i have gfx bench right here we have
metal on the ipad
air and we have both opengl and vulkan
two different tests with two different
architectures on
the tab s7 let's go ahead and compare
them we got our graphics results right
here we have the ipad air on the bottom
the tab seven on the top and i don't
know if you guys can see it that well
from the top camera but
23 fps with both vulcan and opengl for
the tab s7
39.5 fps for the ipad air
that's getting close to double the
graphics performance
that's just insane now we did do a
gaming comparison between the tabas 7
and the ipad pro already
and the tablet 7 performed very well
surprisingly well
for not having that high of graphics
performance definitely check that video
out after this one is over
now if you're wondering why apple gave
the ipad air the same design as the ipad
pro
is because of this it's the magic
keyboard case
because apple is able to support the
magic keyboard case with the ipad air
they're able to sell more of them this
is 300 this is very expensive
now the downside is the finish because
we actually have like a little
scuff or something right here that kind
of sucks but it is definitely the best
keyboard case we've used on
any tablet any device because
you literally just plop it on just like
that and you see the square camera bump
that's for the ipad pro
that way it's able to support both of
these the air and the pro and
this is awesome just having this
floating design
it's incredible with the adjustable
hinge you close it down like that
opens up i mean i love it the only
downside
is that you have touch id now on the
left side so you kind of have to reach
over
with your finger definitely not as good
as
face id now on the other hand we have
the keyboard case for the tab s7
this thing is actually 200 instead of
300 and it
is on sale on amazon so definitely check
the link below
for that price but what i really love
this year
is that instead of sticking it onto the
back
of the tab s7 it uses magnets
finally just like the ipad pro and the
ipad air uses magnets
bam it's on and i also really love this
little flap
that protects the pencil the s pen
unlike
on the ipad air where it's basically
naked it can fall off
this actually protects it and the major
upside for the tab seven is that the
keyboard
is detachable so you literally just plop
it on
there you go you have the kickstand it's
not as convenient as the magic keyboard
there's no kickstand it just happens
with the crazy good hinge but it's
definitely pretty nice
now there are some major differences
with these keyboard cases in terms of
the
keyboard typing feel the track pads
the features like the extra usbc port
for power on the magic keyboard
but i'm not going to get in depth with
that in this video
if you want to see that i actually
compared the ipad pro
with the tablet 7 already in a different
video definitely check that out because
there are some very
interesting differences especially since
you have
dex mode on the tab s7 and that mode is
just
incredible for productivity and
multitasking
now with that said there is a major
downside for the ipad air
the webcam when you're using it with the
magic keyboard it's actually on
the left side right here while the tab
s7
samsung actually thought it through
because it's on the side
but when you're using it with the
keyboard case is perfectly in the center
just like it would be with a laptop
and that gives you a different
perspective let me show you guys what i
mean
this is a webcam and microphone quality
test
using the tab s7 and as you can see i'm
looking down at myself and it looks
pretty normal just like a laptop would
look
and here we are on the ipad air as you
can tell it looks really weird because
i'm looking off to the side because the
webcam
is right there on the side of the ipad
air that's really weird and i can tell
that it's a little bit more
cropped in definitely more cropped in
but you guys let me know how the
microphone quality is
and the video quality of the webcam is
down below now before i give my final
thoughts on these two tablets and which
one is better
i do want to go over some specs and
pricing
as i told you guys before the ipad air
starts at
hundred dollars however you only get 64
gigabytes of storage
with the tab seven you get 128 gigs
for 650 dollars so just 50 bucks more
but you get
more storage which is very nice of
course you get six gigs of ram
compared to four gigs with the ipad air
and if you match both of these up
with 256 gigabytes of storage
the ipad air becomes seven hundred and
fifty dollars and the tab seven
is actually seven hundred and thirty
dollars so
is less expensive on top of that it
comes with the
s pen included compared to the apple
pencil
second gen which is 130 dollars so
it's more expensive if you want the full
package especially if you're trying to
get a keyboard case
which is 200 or on sale and
300 for the magic keyboard so
with both of these you're definitely
getting a less expensive package with
the tab s7
you're getting a lot more value now
let's finally answer the question
which tablet should you be buying in
late
2020 honestly if you want more value
just go with the tab s7 because you're
getting that 120hz display
that helps for the s pen that helps for
gaming
gaming performance is still great even
though the actual
raw performance is better on the ipad
air it's still just fine on this
tablet with this being limited to 60
it's kind of a little bit disappointing
and the value just isn't as good as the
tab
s7 now on the other hand there is a
difference
of software and the ipad air obviously
gets
ipad os it's very reliable you get very
good
resale value which you don't really get
with android tablets
so if you don't really care about the
software
if you don't care about having ipad os
or android
definitely go for the tab s7 but
if you like the apple software i would
still say
that the ipad air is a better choice but
just in terms of
usability value i've got to give the
crown
to the tab seven so there you guys have
it hopefully you enjoy this video
and if you guys want to check out those
differences with the keyboard cases or
the gaming performance we have both of
those videos
right over there with the ipad pro
definitely watch
those videos thank you guys for watching
if you enjoyed it go ahead tap the like
button
click the circle above to subscribe and
we will see you in
the next video